a bipartisan group of senators is
calling for an investigation into how
the u.s. Olympic Committee and USA
Gymnastics handled sexual abuse
allegations against Larry Nasser more
than 250 women and girls including
Olympic gymnasts
accused the former doctor of sexual
assault after three separate convictions
NASA is going to spend the rest of his
life in prison well we spoke with the
parents of five of his victims they
believe many organizations failed to
protect their children how important is
it for members of Congress now that
they're saying we want an investigation
the girls the young ladies they deserve
it you know they've been abused they
need to know that the enablers whether
they're individuals institutions
processes whatever it may be is
eliminated eradicated whether it's usoc
US gymnastics n-c-double-a Michigan
State we're at the top of the range we
really need to know who enabled it and
that's only going to happen from an
independent investigation
so Larry going away was just kind of
like the first chapter in the book and
the healing is started but you can tell
that there's something still hanging out
there that he hasn't been answered to
for organizations they mentioned told
CBS News they either did not hide
Nasser's actions or were never made
aware of abuse they pledged to work to
prevent future abuse well in the next
hour the parents group shares what it
wants to happen next and the message for
other parents